c'est thomas laudien ses reprises je
vous rappelle qu'aujourd'hui nous
jugeons jean yanne qui est inculpé de
désinformation et de propagation de
fausses nouvelles
car il réécrit l'histoire de façon très
personnelle entre autres avec son
dernier film 1h45 avant jésus-christ
également d'excès de vitesse car il
réécrit cette histoire trop vite et il
est également inculpé d'attentats aux
moeurs et de nécrophilie puisque il
s'amuse avec une langue morte
nous allons d'ailleurs entendre ce que
la société à vous reprocher monsieur
jean yanne puisque maintenant on va se
lever devant vous seul avez devant vous
l'esprit français
enfin oui bon d'accord
tout au moins son représentant le
procureur général de la république des
proches française
[Musique]
françaises français belges ben monsieur
le président mon client
mon cher massif central un rassemblent à
bhl raclures du barreau de mes deux
chaises
moshé boggy coucher mesdames et
messieurs les jurés de carnaval public
chéri mon amour aujourd'hui mesdames et
messieurs les jurés français belges
président avocat publics etc
ce n'est point le procureur général qui
s'adresse à vous
par ma bouche à l'ourlet pur purin fait
pour le baiser c'est le
président-fondateur du jeune fan club
dont j'ai toujours tenu farouchement à
être le seul et unique membre brassens
affirme que dès qu'on ait plus de 4 on
est une bande de cons personnellement
j'irai plus loin car je ne craint pas
d'affirmer que dès qu'on ait plus de
deux j'ai l'air d'un con
d'où un besoin quasi irrépressible de
solitude et une crainte presque
hystérique de voir quiconque ose et
partager mes goûts mes idées en vertu
d'un second adage du susnommé brassens
qui dit qu'il vaut mieux se tromper tout
seul qu'avoir raison avec les autres et
oui c'est julio iglesias qui y sont
morts brassens et moi j'ai découvert
l'existence de ce monstre venu sur un
temps de crapulerie rabelaisienne il y à
bientôt 20 ans ça vous rajeunit pas les
mecs ne parle pas de moi c'est moi qui
parle de vous à cette époque bénie où je
finissais de gâcher mes études en
crapahutant frénétiquement sur de
nombreux sommier dont j'ai oublié le nom
aujourd'hui un vent d'impertinence
poivre et commençaient à balayer des
antennes la verve chansonnière un rien
franchouillarde des greniers
montmartrois déjà claude villers perçait
sous jean nohain
certes certes l'image et arbitres
et sûrement pas à davantage de jean
nohain dont la renommée à clermont
ferrand ne nous permet en rien
d'affirmer qu'il a percé dans le massif
central la cour aura évidemment compris
qu'en utilisant cet alexandrin parfait
je ne voulais que parodier bien
innocemment le père hugo qui n'a
d'ailleurs plus rien à secouer
depuis que les asticots du panthéon
l'ont quitté pour aller finir jean
moulin
[Rires]
moment si tu trouves que j'exagère il ya
tu me france culture
ici on respecte rien eux ils respectent
de tous à cette heure s'ils doivent nous
faire les chemins de la connaissance
tu as déjà conduit spéciaux les chemins
de la connaissance aujourd'hui faut-il
réévaluer la spéculation astro
mythologique de freud dans son approche
structuraliste de la psychosomatique
fillier sienne réponse à ça dépend
vous ricanez bande d'incultes je parie
que vous n'avez même pas conscience de
l'immense apport à la psychanalyse que
fut la psychosomatique flier sienne ni
même qui était je sais même pas qui
étaient vilaines filles s or minable
comment peut-on savoir qui est luis rego
et ne pas savoir qui fut willhelm machin
liesse enfin vous avez de la chance j'ai
sous les yeux le texte d'une récente
émission de france culture consacré à
wilhelm fi lles le voir pour ceux qui me
croient pas pour regarder télérama du 20
septembre page 118 je vous lis je vous
lis cette auto rhino laryngologiste
berlinois a été pendant 13 ans l'amie de
freud et son confident
malheureusement son livre les relations
entre le nez et les organes génitaux
féminins présenté selon leur
signification biologique 1897 a été
présenté par certains comme une
élucubration délirante donc jean yanne
est coupable
car jean yanne de son vrai nom ça vous
regarde pas mesdames et messieurs les
jurés
jean yanne est le seul et unique
responsable de mon échec à l'agrégation
de mathématiques à laquelle je me fusse
vraisemblablement présenter nus cet été
d'une part l' influence néfaste sur mon
jeune esprit ouvert aux choses de la vie
de cet immonde poilus des tranchées
radiophonique et d'autre part mon
aversion maladive pour les mathématiques
la première fois que j'ai entendu jean
yanne à la radiophonie je suis sorti de
ma torpeur et de josiane et me suis
enfermé seul avec mon poste de radio
dans la somptueuse garçonnière qui
jouxtait alors le luxueux triplex
d'étudiants que j'avais acquis grâce à
l'immense fortune accumulée par ma
famille pendant la guerre est là
j'écoutais subjugué la rue doit
faubourienne une charge et d'iconoclaste
id salaces et d'irrespect fondamentale
de cet être affreux anarcho nihiliste
qui singe est bossuet raillait les
goitreux et fustigé dans le même panier
de hargne des institutions françaises
aussi sacré est aussi respectable que
l'académie française
l'évêché de mots et la cgt enfin
mesdames et messieurs les jurés jeux
renée 16 à la vie pour moi
l'arrivée sur les ondes de ce messi
diabolique annonçait les temps nouveaux
d'une radiophonie vraiment dégueulasse
enfin c'est tellement dalle en verre
enfin on allait pouvoir prier dans les
urinoirs et pisser dans les bénitiers
amis bigot et dames pipi qui m'écoutait
pour toute réclamation vous écrivez à
luis rego le courrier les imbéciles
france inter 116 avenue du
président-kennedy paris 16e et n'oubliez
pas le temps oui oui mesdames et
messieurs les jurés en vérité je vous le
dit jean yanne a plus fait pour la
promotion du mauvais goût en france que
j'arrose elle skie pour la promotion de
solidarnosc en pologne
un jour j'ai entendu de mes propres yeux
il a osé il a osé expliquer à tout une
francophonie pétrifié d'horreur que
l'auteur de la flûte enchantée ne
s'était pas toujours appelé wolfgang
amadeus mettant enfants il s'appelait en
réalité jean edern mozart comme tout le
monde et c'est parce qu'il mettait de la
boue sur les fauteuils salzbourgeois du
salon de sa maman que cette dernière lui
avait écrit y ait un jour
fous l'camp whom he deus mozart
faut-il salue-t-il que vous soyez tombé
bien bas jean yanne pour avoir sali de
la sorte la mémoire de l'auteur du
boléro de ravel
docushare 312 pardon de ce jour mesdames
et messieurs les jurés ma décision fut
prise
écoeuré par tant de bassesse je me dis
pierre mont garceau wyckoff c'est tout
ça que je m'appelle mon garçon voici je
m'appelle ma fille ça mexique ne peut
pas bosser pierre mon garçon me dis-je
c'est juré tu ne feras jamais de radio
vous comprenez maintenant pourquoi je
vous ai tant jean yanne quant à votre
film 1h45 avancée du cri j'en suis sorti
pantelant d'indignation comment avez
vous osé nous montrer cléopâtre sans
faire allusion à l' affaire antoine est
ce que je montre giroussens combaluzier
mois nous devons respecter la vérité
historique mesdames et messieurs les
jurés
c'est pourquoi avant de céder la parole
à l'avocat le plus badinter qui saura
finir d'accabler son client mieux que je
n'ai su le faire je terminerai en vous
lisant un extrait d'un ouvrage
historique qui m'a rendu célèbre dans ma
famille et qui rétablit la vérité sur
antoine et cléopâtre en rendant à césar
ce qui appartient à saisir
alors je vous lis cet extrait nombreux
furent les héros qui répondait au nom
d'antoine sans parler d'antoine best of
qui ne répondait à aucun nom du fait de
sa douloureuse sur 10 citons en vrac
l'anachorète de la thébaïde qui résiste
à antoine l'anachorète de la thébaïde
qui résistent à la tentation de la chair
à la tentation de la fin à la tentation
de la soif à la tentation du jeu à la
tentation de se gratter et qui est
maintenant saint lô paradis où ils
résistent à la tentation de s'asseoir à
la droite de dieu de peur que ce soit
bon c'est ce qu'on appelle la morale
chrétienne également antoine de padoue
patron du père d'heure d'aiguillés dans
les bottes de foin c'est un antoine de
padoue dix de retrouvés
[Applaudissements]
antoine de bourbon père d'henri iv ou
antoine un matelas inventeur du
calembour dyslexiques
mais le bonne antoine celui de cléopâtre
fut marcus antonius général romain
lieutenant de césar qui bâtit brutus est
qu asus à philippe en 42 je vous le fais
pas dire
quant à cléopâtre ne confondons pas au
fil de l'histoire du monde
nombreuses furent également les héroïnes
qui répondait au nom de cléopâtre sans
parler de cléopâtre denis qui se faisait
appeler la mer à des fins purement bien
quand tu me mets la botte la bonne
cléopâtre celle d'antoine fut cléopâtre
set tu entends me julie vient pas de
recette 7e reine d'égypte 69 30 avant
jésus-christ dont la stupéfiante beauté
laissait les hommes dans un état
direction douloureuse incommensurable
qui par comparaison on faisait paraître
son nez tout petit d'où l'expression
aurait s'il n'y avait pas que le nez
tout en cléopâtre et que la tête beauté
ses yeux au nombre de deux presque aussi
grand l'un que l'autre
ses oreilles délicatement tournée
qu'elle nous est dans le coup les jours
de mistral et ses seins et ses saints
dont les pointes rose et se teintait de
violer quand elle marchait dessus par
ailleurs cléopâtre avait un accent
oriental sur l'oreiller et un accent
circonflexe sur le a
quand antoine la vie pour la première
fois il sentit l'oeuf à se dérober sous
ses pas alors qu'à l'habitude c'est le
sol c'est dire à quel point il était ému
lui même était fort bel homme est
presque aussi rôti que paul newman dans
prends moi sur l' exodus observons de
papillons l'élitiste il se jeta sur
elles et ils s'aiment et ils s'aimèrent
violemment jusqu'à la mort d'antoine à
la bataille d'actium les vérifier parce
que j'étais tellement bourré hier soir
que je sais plus si j'ai trouvé l'axiom
dans le dico dans l'armoire à pharmacie
[Musique]
désespéré par la mort brutale de son
amant cléopâtre se suicida le jour même
en se jetant sous le métro pyramides
je crois que ça devait être l'armoire à
pharmacie fidèles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait étonnant non